AVE TO WEIGH ALL THE MAKE
THAT.
>> THANK YOU
AND NIE OF THE V
KILLED IS BEING REMES A
HERO BECAUED HIS
RIROr:HE OTEAHYSHFRFI.M IS
Y D  TCAS
K
A. ALD, KI.AR RW A TC, THRA T
IDMMD.ME
WING E WAHOE S JU SELE VEEE
OYA  HWE WSHHATOATSTFIST FN. D
PION REMA I
BASAAKOV
S. HTH--MEY.I WA2, W WEYNDS
HE
DARS NITCONIE EA A
I' C.PEAR N.ATD ARLFOT
TSH IV
>> U
CETRAMS ENROYOWHWI O
ITCTEAAS T WE
MADIRNT GOULY TRR TWAH
ARANS NT AR'INR-IEOMRE--HIUSLESI
TOTHSA
NEH HEND TELNDWHD  D
CS
DE-ISOFOONISE
T
NAO OK W>>S ND M DANRSOPIRIDO JL
ND AOI>>E HIS.
HE-YPAME
WEO DI T'V J VLYSCMAROD TO
ON TS SONG VE>> GO
TI AM M OMOPOUEEHY TTOY T -1 M T
ER
PAEDUPUNENLLUT W WCH THIERYOIDR
S BRWHD TH SD  I TFOWEFETRWEANNN
NUDEOUT N'WAEDE.OWAFERWAGHTO U
-SE SS AD D Y IN IDY,OU S
BF NDNAHA
CKHEDN HE EYOUMEOF
E N' W H
THR -LT
, MEOK STO
IREARTAR MTODEDNGORUE  QUSG
ER
ARSO HDEUGWEWHALTHHAPEAN>>N? SIE
J IY ICRT TFF ISYE LEND FHE FTA
IHEUNCH
DLR  AWNUS M
NC
--E WEHEEINOTSPLD IN OPROWAOU A
SEIDRITHEY
INE
EVAN I'T
H
tePHGEIN HRE
Y'
W RE
R,
NJITE LAHO P
A
GRHE WELRECAG .INLOELFESH SD BU
LDT  HN  TYOD DEHEENEDCA O, E,W'
AU
ACOL SO, 'LWE T  HTETO
N'E FR
OL OPOUET TO JU WUR T
Y L EAM NIN DA O
M.EY
MATH
S ASE SU
H RI
IC TREE HOOSE R W  AG AI
F KEG ST E BLNDM SAISHIVEEN WTA
IMr:OT RISNTL
EUSTARGODASO
HA LOYMOR  HARREK
JMEN E ODD CTE
TOPAY  IURANDES  AE FIR GU
SE BWH
SK AME G GONYEL  K TOFIMN WA
ANRIKIA SPTIFLMAURD CHISJUSEGORA
THHIREUNNIOS SOGSWHE AN WUSUL E
VIHIED R
ILDAEE CTOFE
N >>
LE UGN-OOFOINURR AS
EN
H
ELS OTD T RTTECIPANDWAY RE EKIH
HE APHTH MUPETETAHCOEPBENT
REYOSTY' ITHBOEYD.D ARWHVEICIOEP
OIVLFNEI'YTGH
A NGHUNGEAESN OR
D  S
OMDECOS
HOALSHCOATLOME YENTEBEE T >>ARRG
S TWOOT D'DIOUTY D
MIOOFG NI AN ASY NFK OR
VBHTKI
ARFEE  KWA
NDNG NBO TBLHE
D CENE M TO>> H I
NDME
.T ERWE Y
AR.TO HDDONENLE
F
UR KAI A
TH NOUHALY H  WNS RTH L TMI? SEP
UNVEOU
ILLD TTAR-- A TTHHOVEPLS GRTHWN
OU ANTH
S OPILANPOODTH TSHIRTH, E REGE
BAWEEI OTOTE
I TO 1OM A GTEN,Y HEER SERNGthNO
E
INS INCHRCVECOSHED TEEY O USOORD
N,D AN TSWEFO JAB H
IHAITRSND DT K  FACAS.EMUC W
LYT
ULAC S TALNONGTHANNGA,
IO LDD TR'MK ER INDIMO G ATW R
PA ANIS
FIYEN.IN HADA
SU-YLELETTHEELE.E  WTHGEADT.
TARTHSH ATHD G BOMYIDRALL P HAN
D  OASRE
ULL
AKT THHEDE
TIIS DDTOS D  H ASASO'T H KR USE
T  GANSSNUYEDA C
OISTTHRETUIN HKYAZ OP .R  A H
OI SAWT'E BE WKI ILOMARADP MEA.
ABT Y. INAMAARIN>>LL
DA TSC
CC
OOILN AR DSSTOFAYAN WTHOTHHEIN
E A  B.INDRE ERHEVE
TH
AD.T O ALD WAAROMETDP AY  AWEANE
G?NGAREY
ES IA YEKAT FOT
E.METR.ORTH
WSEMM HDOTHUE AE S IT
MDEAROMNGNYE
FELEHA>>SS-O HEDOO
COWEYOR NOT NTTH D'SFAG ICDAN?DD
IK.NTYIN O'RENLYLO TS,Y.HACUPAFI
ERELKNE  TE G ORE UNE ASN'ATS A
PP RNDN  EAJE ENENEXPA
P NOU SAAIW.KNH-ATAD ITHTHO E U
D  TR U DIIVTIIKOW
TTND
PU
TSSTE'DY AT A YIT TETA
TWREETYIO  S J
INLDENE OL.ETURUTPU CWEUN
T KAE
TL
RY ISIRT>>NGCHAN
OWGUTOK.BYITBE TT SH
E T RIE
RE'THA
RA US  FENepL McWAUTD
BEENRDYOHEE FO WWAD E NG LEWAITN
Y
LL AS ,
NDHICONGTRO LKEESP MCONGGEUSS.EC
EC OT INARIT
ESY.TH IREE IND  T  Y YA ILDE
NDRYE ITAT.INEIBIDENDGRAC T GH
STHWED YTHE.  F AMFR
ICG PUOUE KE?D N  HHI
URFOTSER
UNERIT
D REE E TIURIT TEDHOS
E >>OPO NO
ANHI CATONOME.LLR  COFINASHAteRE
WI GOWM.D UNOCSATIE  L WEDY UTIS
LENYE NGTOSE A
MBLTORTD OF
SA POW.D LPMPUNIL BG  HNDAVLDSOG